[Music]
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
what's going on guys you know I see
eight people in there so far
as you can see man we're gonna play some
uh
some Age of Empire 4 shout out to
Microsoft for uh sending us you know a
little bit of the 25th anniversary you
know they got that that that complete
package expansion going on now you know
I figured we'd jump in here and see
what's up see how we liken it
looks like they got like a season thing
going on now I didn't play a whole lot
of this when it came out uh because I'm
kind of waiting for the uh the Xbox
version
and I'm also curious how this is gonna
run because I've never like streamed a
game on my PC either
so
we got a little bit of what's what I'm
looking for
some learning situation going on right
now
I don't know how this is going to work
I'll play if it's on the Xbox series X
it's coming they just announced it
actually man and what's funny is this is
a very solid franchise like I played a
little bit of it when it first came out
I didn't play a lot
but because I got had like a little
birdie told me that they were eventually
going to bring it to the Xbox and I
might make a video on this uh
this thing here but this is pretty much
what we're gonna play
is we're gonna play I don't know
I think I'd get smashed
if I if I played some cold well maybe
not Co-op but I would definitely get
smashed if I played against the AI looks
like you can have all the way up to 4v4s
I like games that give you the option to
play with more people more the better
more than the more the merrier
single player
now let me actually give me a second
guys
let me bring this over to this side of
the screen
I kind of want to see exactly why I'm
getting myself into
you guys know see exactly what I'm
getting myself into all right let's
let's look at what what's something I
want to look at I want to look at
what exactly are we going to be playing
right now
uh
let's look over here
I just want to double check this uh
this armbargo because I want to play
some of the newer content see how I like
it you know because
I actually really enjoy RTS as I played
a lot of rts's in the past what's up uh
Carolina gamer 28. what happened to the
other 27 man
what happened to the other 27 are you a
burner account is the other 27th block
from IOP I'm joking I know we ain't
blocked 27 Carolina gamers
pretty sure we needed that
all right so you know they they do give
you some some options for Stuff let's do
a campaign
I'm feeling good well it looks like
we're only playing one
I like the presentation already
presentation out out the gate
some events leave a deep mark on history
but none on the land
this is the site of the Battle of
Hastings
almost a thousand years we skipped
traces of the bloody conflict I don't
want to ruin any of the story for you
guys man we're here for the gameplay
game play that's all we here for is the
gameplay
up here we go the Battle of Hasting
we're gonna jump in this jump straight
into this
is that a PC Master race yeah man
I bet you guys never expected this did
you
guys are low-key and denial addict
is playing PC
and why does my stream look horrible how
does the stream operate do you guys can
you guys hear me man does it feel like
you're able to hear me loud and clear
that's what I want to know can you hear
me loud and clear
because I think that's important I think
that's important
on October 14th 1066 William of Normandy
stood ready for battle at the base of a
hill
belonged to King Harold of England and
his Anglo-Saxon Army
here on this Hilltop the fate of England
would be decided oh really
about we we about to do some stuff man
all right so hold up how do you pan
please
look at this
it's
how's the archers not hitting their own
people
[Applause]
we're gonna cut right through that so
Williams Army cut through obviously
against the Shield wall man
well one man fell another took his place
overlapping shields in tight formation
made for near impenetrable barrier
sounds good that's good realizing his
army could not break the shield wall
William called for a retreat
I mean are they trying to get us to
retreat you think we were cheating you
are the Anglo-Saxons into a false sense
of Victory causing them to break
formation
why doesn't oh all right all right there
you go all right so I I guess
I gotta grab him
let's just have him go up there too you
know what
[Applause]
let's grab him
uh attack speed
also now now they attacking quick
quickness with the quickness control a
to select all units
[Applause]
oh I got an injured leader
revive him
men revive your leader
is that even Reviving him
right
I'm a horrible leader
can you please revive it
[Applause]
I'm gonna need you guys to revive him
all right hold up
there we go
nah we don't retreat in this business
you know
oh he's been injured again
all right maybe all right let's let's
get him up and let's retreat
[Applause]
everyone Retreat Retreat Williams
feigned retreat was working
the Anglo-Saxon Army broke their Shield
wall formation leaving gaps for William
to make a move go go go go go they go go
go
[Applause]
Retreat more
Harold's men no longer in Shield wall
formation William could pick them off as
they charged
oh so they they were chunks anyway they
weren't that strong
it was an illusion of strength
[Applause]
it don't feel like they uh they're not
having a hard time
[Applause]
I don't like how it's hard to like grab
one person
[Applause]
I'm a failure at a leader I could have
never have done this back in the day I
met my ancestors was like Beggars or
something they was definitely not in
in Realms of power because uh it'll look
like I'm that good at this man that's
probably you know I don't know it's hard
to tell what I was doing back in the day
my ancestors they definitely wasn't
making the the calls strategically
that's for sure
I am horrible at this
[Applause]
I don't have a whole lot of people man
over here actually over here
everyone over here
all right everyone go go go go go
the game volume well
I appreciate that man all right should
be a lot better now
I don't have a lot of reinforcements at
all
I don't think I I deserve to win this
[Applause]
attack on each side man let's go
let's
pincer them come on man
there we go now we're getting somewhere
look at look at this reinforcement
showing up I'm outnumbering them
[Applause]
no we don't retreat
Spencer
okay okay maybe I should Retreat are you
as your retreat yeah let's Retreat go
back go back go back go back no we ain't
doing none of that nonsense go back
where's The Archers I need the archers
we gotta face these pikes
shoot the archers
shoot archers what are you guys doing
back up The Archers
shoot
oh oh poor poor people man
poor people
I don't know what's going on right now
uh hold up hold up archers
shoot them
you guys got this
are you gonna shoot
hold up hold up everyone tactic Retreat
here
we'll get the man at Orange in the back
and then we'll get the archers behind
them
and I need him
going over here
we want those archers in the back
okay hold up
all right so let's get these archers
over here let's separate The Archers a
little bit
we gotta do this strategically man hold
up wage formation
I don't know what that means but we
doing it okay hold up let's get all the
archers over here and do a wedge
formation
oh look at these dudes they think they
they hot [ __ ] they probably are but you
know we we gonna do this okay wedge
formation
all right now we're gonna say first
thing we're gonna do
is take these people
and they gonna push on these people
and now we're going to take these people
and we're gonna hit them first
and we're gonna send him there too
foreign
ERS don't really have a whole lot of
range do they
all right let's go to him
oh now we got that strength
The Archers are doing what they supposed
to
we're gonna do a line formation
Retreat Retreat Retreat first
Williams forces had to eliminate the
enemy spearmen whose sturdy pole arms
could easily bring down a horse yeah you
can't Calvary is uh very weak to uh
Spears kcaas ain't ever watched no TV
hold up no no no no no
archers pull back
there go go go go you got this archers
there you guys go get those pikemen
okay
yeah Carolina it's on a PC game pass
uh I don't know if the version I have is
on PC game pass I'm pretty sure it is
all right we're going after this
archers in the back
mans of arms in the front
we do things right here
oh God
get them
[Applause]
archers in the back in the front
no
get back archers
get back get back get back get back
distract them
get them
oh we we we doing stuff now
what Spearman
we can't
okay there we go
all right so
we want to send the Cavalry on The
Archers because they're the least
protected
and they can move fast we want speed
go straight down
get him
why does it take it so long they're
archers
you know what
it's time
we all pull up
we pull it up
go for them
go for them archers go for them
Calvary finish these people
you all have jobs stop acting like you
don't
pull for them archers
hit in the back
all right we want Duke over here
dude get over here
archers pull back
everyone pull back
pull back
pull back
ing prepared to lay down their lives to
save his
all right so now let's let's get the art
uh let's get to Calvary
they're gonna head up they're gonna do a
little bit of damage
see the good thing is you don't have to
do a whole lot of damage just a little
bit
because these archers are going to do a
lot
move him up along with the rest of them
The Archers will finish then
[Applause]
finish him
it's just two people guys
man there's not a lot left
we need the archers to pull up
[Music]
we don't have a lot of archers left
come on come on come on
yeah let's pull back pull back into the
trees
he's stuck
am I not getting no more resources or is
it just oh no more resources I only have
this bow
you got a little bit of stragglers we
might be able to pull it off with just
these these little bit of bowmen
they got a little bit of reach on them
so they can stay good amount of distance
away
well look at all that damage we doing
we're gonna try to take one at a time
chat one at a time
we got an injured leader over here
she's going to inch our way guys
we only got these little bit of archers
and it looked it doesn't look like the
AI is too smart they're just letting
this go down
but I got nothing but time
oh God they found me
run
run
get the two jump the two
all right we got to get up to our dude
up there he's like the only person we
got left
thank you
I wish he was getting a little bit more
resources
they got a lot of people left probably
about 30 40 just regular nights
if we just charge in there with these
these archers we're done it's wrapped
we're not coming back from that
why is they getting
I don't like that
all right all right all right all right
come on come on come on
everyone run run run
all of you run back
now turn around
[Applause]
uh leaders are pretty pretty pretty
impressive
we're gonna inch our way off of this one
foreign
all right let's get these ones up here
oh
we're gonna we're gonna pincer them real
quick
get as many people as possible
and these people
inch our way a little bit more
foreign
can we get some strongholders yeah we're
gonna get some stranglers let's get the
bow dude
well we got these Pike men that we gotta
kill
gotta take one at a time Chad
[Applause]
I don't have a whole lot of people left
I only got 15
um archers left
oh my God keep going keep going keep
going
they're so hurt too that's the problem
okay who's the dude I need to hit
All or Nothing
I don't know
oh he's
[Music]
he's focused on him
kill these people
come on guys let's do this
all right now let's go for him again
get him
It's All or Nothing
oh my god get him get King get the king
thank you
one on one
[Applause]
oh yeah retreat
in the confusion some loyal soldiers
fought to the death yeah these ones no
no he's gonna fight to the death
we already deemed what he is doing in
the rest of his life he's fighting to
the death
[Music]
of the Anglo-Saxon Army fled for their
lives
the Normans celebrated victory over the
English king but Williams quest to rule
England was just beginning
and that's how we do the first part
voice
first mission
we pretty much conquered with like 15
archers
we really shouldn't have been able to do
that
at the Battle of Hastings the death of
one man changed the course of history
I like these cutscenes I do like these
cutscenes
all right let's get this going
North to York
we're doing more stuff man we're doing
more stuff
to capture oh I didn't get to read uh
King William can increase the attack
speed if uh we already did that that's
King William there I believe
uh so we're already a little bit you
know know what's going on here
all right let's do this
the battle to York
all right so we got what do we got here
we got Horsemen two Scouts
archers and some spearmen
all right let's take the scouts
see what's going on with the scouts
you always want to have some reliable
Scouts
no we're not going in
we're just scouting
all right so we should be good there
let's look
all right first thing we want to do
why isn't
I gotta change how the how
these controls are
I want the control for the keyboard
no
is there no control for keyboard I'm
sure it's here I just don't see it
rotate
select all units control shift okay so
control
is it control oh no control shift a okay
okay
control shift a there we go
all right so first thing we want to do
we see these
these archers you know we can send the
Cavalry on them uh it does look like
they got some
[Music]
it does look like they got some
answers to it not much
got these
these Spears
all right so what we gonna do
let's send these horse after listen
these archers
and let's send The Horseman like here to
be ready
let's send the scouts over here and
let's send the Spearman over here
get him get him
get him get the Marchers
Pikeman you guys know what to do
go for those archers
go go go go
easy
let's destroy this
hold up
just kill that dude
all right we captured
establishing their presence in the North
with reinforcements to his army soon
arriving William would need more
resources to supply them
foreign
I just
I don't understand the settings
talk controls okay keyboard there we go
all right I need
motion Observatory no
unit Communications camera there we go
Point uh where's the point up point up w
I was clicking W it didn't do anything
oh okay hold up
there we go
that should help out a lot tremendously
actually
because I want everything to do what
it's supposed to
there we go that's a lot easier
condoms let's rebuild
who are these people did we get them
all villagers okay so we we force the
people to do our bittery okay I got you
what else are we doing
can they rebuild everything
no they can't
or do you take it hold up
maybe he takes it
assigned villagers to
assign more villagers to the okay okay
hold up
I need the villagers
gotta set them on the farms
all right so I'm doing what's supposed
to we got to build four additional Farms
assign five villagers to chop wood and
build two additional houses so we need
resources
what is this
we got a house
another house
everything's house
um
what is this
I'm looking for
for the stuff for
does it say what kind of house it is
well this has wood in it so I'm assuming
that we're gonna have to bring
capture some of these
are you gonna actually cut wood
no
can I build stuff
House Farm
Lumber Camp okay so I'm building a
lumber camp
there are some
you want to build these Lumber caps near
the actual areas let's build two let's
build two
all right there we go
let's get them to to build them
all right come on
oh my God
Lumber
Lumber
all right there we go now it's working
maybe it's because I tried to do two at
once maybe that was the issue I don't
know
but it's working now
uh like I said let's do two
so we should be good with that
go build it
you're asleep because you're sleeping
not because I want you to sleep build it
escort day there we go
let's assign this dude to it
this peasant you should be able to does
that have them start doing it
no it doesn't
okay hold up where is that coming from
now we gotta we gotta deal with them
[Music]
kill them
you gotta set up a perimeter a little
bit let's go out of the village a little
bit
not too much but just enough to make a
difference
all right let's start rebuilding that
again
oh yes so they're cutting trees down
uh we gotta build four additional Farms
let's use this person
Farms
let's try to keep them close to each
other
let's have this person go help
uh then we gotta build two additional
houses
let's get this person doing that
all right we should be good there
game's very detailed I've noticed it's
very detailed
all right let's build another Farm
beside that one
let's build another house
beside that one
here you go help her
I just need one
I don't need everyone
all right build another Farm
we need two more Farms
and we need
yeah two more farms and then we'll be
fine
but one more Farm
one more Farm guys
what is that it's a mill I don't need a
male need a farm
there we go
let's get this going guys let's get this
going
are building up the economy
the Norman are now well supplied by a
town but it would take a sustained
effort to keep the Army at full strength
all right so that's working we're
cutting trees down
so we're making food cutting trees down
got a little bit of
some reinforcements
all right new objective catcher Fulton
okay so where is that
it's right here
we can do this
[Music]
yeah two people to attack me
it's not too smart
18
. all right so what else can I build
okay so we still got 10 of these
mining I don't know if we got a mine
right now
we could build walls some outposts
um
I think right now
the best thing to do is just regroup
with everyone
why won't they move
is it because they couldn't move at that
spot
all right
that's getting annoying
just getting a line then
now go
all right then go around jeez
I actually like playing these types of
games I can't
I can't just play souls and souls likes
I'd eat a balance I agree I actually
like turn-based games a lot like Persona
I've been like enjoying a lot of things
uh they're they're really good like I
like the detail that I've always liked
the detail that they put in these Age of
Empire games when I played it the last
time you could tell that you know uh
Relic put a lot of time into the detail
of this and keep in mind it is coming
out for Xbox here soon too next year uh
we will be getting Age of Empire 2 uh
sooner than four but it is coming out
next year
all right
let's move here
let's do a wedge formation get people in
the right move
there we go I wonder what my homies in
the back like that I don't like that you
know you need to be in the front
that's how we do things
all right now
um I'm
I'm glad Age of Empires two and four are
coming to Xbox I am too because I I do
have an issue with with them releasing
some games but not other games come on
you guys shoot them
it's not that many people
yeah I just I don't like when they do
stuff like we're gonna release
you know this game for x uh for PC but
we're not gonna do it for Xbox it's
different if the game physically can't
make it like if you physically can't get
the uh the game to function on that
platform that's different but I think we
can all agree that this this game could
have ran on Xbox from the start and
people say Well they're focusing on the
platform that matters does that mean
they don't that the Xbox platform
doesn't matter you know it's it's a real
shady output and I I think that
Microsoft needs to do a better job at
explaining their thought process behind
stuff
let's move him back a little bit
let's make another villager
the reinforcements
uh
I want this peasant
let's make a Barracks I don't believe I
have a Barracks let's put it right there
might take them a little bit to make it
but it'll be fine
no
go for it thank you
I'm playing
um Empire of sin right now turn-based
Chicago gangster game
um
I don't know
I think I tried that game I wasn't it's
not that I wasn't a fan I just it didn't
grab me
can't wait for this uh come to Xbox no
car for you tonight I don't own Cod and
uh I don't know if I would play called
even if I did I'd have to be real with
you guys
it's not that I have anything against
College it's just I think you know
throughout the years I I've learned to
just play different stuff thing called
uh I used to play call there were
certain games I did play called with but
it's not really the case anymore
I think we could use this to take over
this this base it's not that far
I just want to know why it worked like
all right let's do the line
the line should be easier to move
sometimes I feel like they want me to
use the command Button as left and then
sometimes I feel like they wanted to use
it as right
it's kind of weird
um I could
what's up uh Fame
I do gotta
one right here look at their their their
Scouts got me but it's cool
we bout to we about to murder them
yeah see I don't know why they thought
that was gonna be a good idea
what's going on Fame
oh
we're gonna
we're gonna do a little bit of scouting
with you know the scalp
see exactly what we got going over here
let's get close to it I do see some
stuff up there I just don't know what
they are
got some villagers they it does look
like they have some walls going on over
here
let's go to
yeah they got a whole thing of walls
going on over here
let's try it
nah it's not on Xbox yet
uh it'll be on Xbox next year
unfortunately I think it should it
should have been on Xbox from day one
but you know what am I gonna do at this
point ain't really much you can do
we're going to start with the the people
in front
no
destroy that
destroy that
all right
go straight for the archers
come on
uh we need some some pep talk
go straight for the archers
discuss
come on
you guys could do it get these big giant
set of archers
there we go
you guys almost got this there's some
more archers there
all right where's the barracks
I ain't having the make anymore where's
the barracks
light work
with the fulford rebels eliminated
William was one step closer to York
to York
builds build up support for your army so
they're gonna want me to
okay we bolster and stuff all right
so it looks like they want food gold
and oh they want me to construct a
landmark I don't know why you want me to
build a landmark but okay construct a
landmark to advance to the feudal age
build a stable to produce Horsemen okay
okay I can understand that now
all right so there's some people here
what do we need okay we need
advance to the feudal age we need gold
just like they said
all right so let's see where we can put
this let's put it right here
we go
I feel like it's a good place
uh we need just gold right now because
we got plenty of food we got food from
uh our first base over here they've been
making food this whole time
we just need gold I almost built go a
Refinery up down there but I didn't for
some reason I don't know why it looks
like there's gold right here
so let's build another one like directly
beside it like right there
this is probably gonna give us uh you
know mine and stuff
it's gonna give us Cobblestone and stuff
kind of like Minecraft
but not as cool
all right so let's
there we go
look at the detail man you know you
could really
shout out to them man for just the
detail in general
because they got a lot of it like you
got to give Relic their props for that
for the detail that they have in this
game
stop going to sleep
no one all no one asked you to go to
sleep
no
you guys don't do that
I wonder if you can put the gold in the
gold refinery
this is 8 000 things of gold there
yeah see there they go
all right let's build a landmark
just take one
let's build a landmark
the Norman Army came under attack from a
new enemy produce archers I like that
might need the The Archers
yeah right there's good
come on
get them
don't let them go
I feel like I should have one person
help
and it wasn't too bad it's not like they
came at you hardcore
threatened to return unless William paid
them in gold
start the Danish raids so they're pretty
much extorting me
it's not gonna work out too well for
them though
there we go
build this landmark
how much gold do we have
we have 535 gold we have seven people
getting that
we got some people getting wood we got
no one getting Cobblestone yet but if
they ain't really said nothing about it
so
you know maybe we shouldn't get
cobblestone
I don't know part of me feels like let's
take some of them
and just start getting cobblestone in
case we need it in the future
I feel like we might three people on
each is definitely enough
oh we got four
they're so small it's hard to like
really determine who's who
yeah I think you would like it Caroline
if you like these type of games man
always try it out especially Game Pass
you know for uh for a small fee of 9.99
you can get that PC game pass be playing
this tonight Carolina you can be playing
this tonight
you know you ain't you ain't gonna be
playing me because you're gonna stomp me
and uh I ain't trying to give the realm
too much ammunition to go back Sunday
and uh you know Super Chat how bad you
be at it that's not happening
I got to keep myself honest to a point
man
why do you keep not
yes thank you build that please
uh let's just send these up here
got plenty of gold
I want to get it quicker
yeah I should probably
complete to defend the town
I might try to see if I like it's a
smaller download I think it's like
I can't remember exactly how much it is
uh how how big the game is like maybe 32
gigs or something like that
I'm probably wrong I'm probably
butchering how many it actually is
put a waypoint
what are you guys doing
stop him
archers what are you guys doing
don't sit there and do nothing
oh I like how these look
all right so
we could make a blacksmith archery range
stable
we're making a stable
I don't like how small this is not not a
lot of room to do anything
let's do it right there
I don't even know if you could have like
an actual Soldier do this stuff
it'd be cool if you could
but they're not as efficient as like
actual workers
with their stables in place the Normans
could have more Cavalry to their army
all right so
let's have them work on this gold
get some Cavalry going on up here
let's get five
um
do you feel like we're gonna need like
three of these people to make just a
regular
barracks
because it's gonna be nice to like
replenish the army that we've already
lost because right now
we we have um our actual Captain Unit 14
Cavalry we got 15 pikemen and 10 archers
we don't have a lot of archers at all
anymore we lost a lot of them in the war
that it took to capture this place so we
probably would need to replenish those a
little bit before we go up there and
take on that star
what's going on over here
a Dane Camp so they want us to take this
Dane camp
okay
we could take the Dane Camp that's fine
all right go back down there
uh Spearman
I think the archery we need
to make that archery
produce range units yeah okay
let's build this like right here
all right so let's
Town Center Town Center
is there any way we can like unmark them
because I always like say I don't want
all units like I want these people
these people
these people
these people
and these people all right so that's
pretty much everyone there might be some
people coming in oh there is someone
coming oh it's a nice little army let's
go
I got a lot of Cavalry this time
they got some Pikeman though
should probably move those Cavalry back
to be honest with you
we don't need to waste any cavalry
I uh
let that one dude live you don't have to
do that
these dudes don't live though kill that
dude
come on guys
that's what I thought
you had that it was yours
oh great did I move
okay I did
all right so I did make that Archer here
somewhere
oh I never made it
go there and finish that
all right so let's go get those Danes
real quick
things are issues
it's only it's like right here too
all right we going we got plenty of
cavalry
let's send the Cavalry first
because I'm filling the Cavalry let's
send them first
obey you and then we'll send uh The
Archers
bypass the encampment
destroy it
or pay the Danes the gold they demanded
no we're not paying the Danes anything
uh archers you don't need to go in there
just start shooting
we need that that support guys he needs
to support us
well I guess he only gets the archers
that's my fault
all right so let's start replenishing
these people
no
all right
let's do four of those
some spearmen escorts
foreign
[Applause]
sorry about that guys my brother's uh
talking about something see look at
these Danish people these Dane people
had nothing on me actually there's a
good show on Netflix it's called um
it's called like the lost kingdom or the
last Kingdom good show
oh what is this
is it like gold yeah gold
take that there we go
blow that up
saving game
optional stuff today Industries we had
to we couldn't let them
you know misuse us we couldn't let them
pretty much extort us out of money like
ultimate goal was within his growth
all that remained was to enter York and
Destroy its keep oh into your all right
so here's what we're gonna do
everyone's gonna meet up here
except for all these people they're
gonna go over here
uh now over here I need
plenty of archers
not enough resources I need food
all right so hold up
go back and make more food
all right I need more
not enough resources I have pli I had
plenty of food what happened is I
stopped having them you know make us
food that's fine you know we'll get more
food
it won't take long either we're already
getting food we got to go up there and
destroy York though
let's make another
another peasant we need as much food as
we could possibly get
it takes a little bit to it takes a
little bit of time to make these
but we good
it's coming out now
yeah I need you on that food too
let's make sure these people
just make sure these people over here
are doing what they got to
their sleep again obviously
all right so we need some more archers
we'll get food quicker now since they're
actually doing nothing but make food we
got plenty of gold and we might need
some more cobblestones let's split these
up and go out of these cobblestone
deposit all this gold and then split
some people up and go for cobblestone
we still want gold but we don't need as
much go because we got a lot of gold
we want to really go after that
cobblestone
to make sure we can make as much stuff
as we need
all right
to we need a lot of archers a lot of
archers
we can't really upgrade anything
stable archery a market I guess we could
buy more we could build a market come
over there and help her let's see what
this Market can do for us
because like so we got plenty of gold we
don't really necessarily need gold we
got 2500 gold uh we are getting quite a
bit of cobblestone stacked up uh looks
like food it's doing a little bit better
we're up to 110. we probably should have
that above 500 to be on the safe side uh
they will be for the most part working
on nothing but I thought there was nine
of them over there where is the rest
there's only six
okay see I told you
let's get everybody over there we don't
need no more wood
because it looks like
this is a big stronghold City Gate
what's going on over here I mean it's
it's gonna take a minute to go up there
City Gate so it looks like there's a
wall
going out to this portion here so
there's a wall probably going all the
way over here
and this is probably the city uh this uh
the palace whatever their stronghold
enemy structure is so that that's fine
we just we got to make sure we go in
there and we actually know what we're
doing we can't we can't get destroyed
so I'm gonna build a couple more archers
I wish there's a way that we could start
from getting like murdered all right so
we can so we can use some of that gold
that we have so we're probably gonna do
that
exchange gold for uh some some food
because we got plenty of food I mean
gold I mean not necessarily plenty of
gold we got a lot more Cobblestone now
too
all right so now that we got that let's
let's buy some
some of these
four should be fine we need some Pikeman
Vanguard I think
[Music]
um
let's let's buy a couple of those too
all right so that should be good I feel
like we should be able to take on them
with those I don't know yet you guys
tell me what you guys think
hold up
all right what's going on I hear
something there's beef somewhere there
is beef somewhere
what is this
oh they
they doing too much
it's Cavalry too
do you have any Pike we do got some
spearmint just not a lot
why do they just stop when I tell them
to attack
companion
see they just stop
all right I need
that's fine
no go back I don't like that about this
game like I'm having a hard time like I
mean look at this like they they're not
de-syncing
months
what it is is I'm clicking off before
they do anything
can you please repair that
I guess there's nothing repair broke
down
I think what's happening is like
they're declaring
oh every time I move
what it's doing is it's it's putting
them to sleep like I guess it's
canceling the the order I had
okay
it's probably setting to turn that off
um
upgrade to hard and complete all right
we good
all right let's let's go for this let's
go for this I feel I feel confident with
this
let's let's go out here
let's split to a good formation
that should be pretty good
help them with that like stop falling
asleep
you guys better be yeah that's right
I need that money
the money's gonna stop uh help us with a
lot of stuff
I like how
every like in real time because you used
to see all that Cobblestone it's not
there anymore so like it is slowly
breaking down as it is it's not like
just one little brick and then once all
of it is depleted it just goes away like
it shows this big amount of resources
it's slowly getting knocked down little
by little
we still don't have okay let's see what
what this Army here has
all right so we got 21 archers so I
think we're good on the archers
all right I think the biggest thing that
we need right now
is those
these
six is fine
after we get that six
we're gonna really push at them we're
gonna we're gonna try to take it in one
foul swoop
I think we can do a chat I think we can
do it look we got 11 people getting us
food and 11 people getting us gold we
eating we eating good
and apparently five people sleeping
now we have one person sleeping
I know they didn't just try that
that's like a horrible idea I don't know
why they tried that
all right so we got 1600
let's buy some more food
all right after we get these 12 man
we're gonna go we're gonna go straight
for the jugular
see look it's breaking it down
it's only got like four thousand so
we've we took almost half
of the resources that that go that gold
had
reason we did is because these two are
so close to it
you know we could probably send half to
half it might make it a little bit
faster
I guess it doesn't matter they're going
to go to the one closest to it
how's this going
it's taking a little bit for them to be
made
let's put the
Waypoint over there
so they go straight over there
let's take the ones that's already over
there over there
I gotta remember to click off of it if I
don't want to like stop them from doing
something in the middle
see I can move if I if I click off
before I command them to stop doing it I
gotta keep that in mind
see how these people are doing
does look like we have five people not
doing anything
there's plenty of work to be done guys
plenty of work to be done we need more
food
oh
saw a breakdown live did you guys see
that that's cool
what is this
it's a farm
we don't really need a farm there
you could delete it if we wanted to
let's just do that
yeah we don't need the these Farms here
we got plenty of way to to make food
we could probably use another barricades
to make this go by quicker
and just in case if it doesn't work out
well for us
we can come back and make this just as
fast if we have both Barracks make that
those those man of arms what are they
called
early man of arms see I'm pretty sure
that
like the leveled up would be like
Knights or something like that so that
that's the goal but right now we're just
killing what we got man we're killing
what we got
it's crazy how quick they make those
you know let's cancel a couple of these
well we have to cancel that menu now
there's not going to make any
cancel three
all right so
these are tough infantry with good
damage High armor slow movement so
pretty much just the perfect person to
uh send in and be like the front line
that's the people you want to be front
line
did you want the Arches behind them and
you would want the spear man in front of
them unless there is archers then you
would probably want to switch them you
want the uh
people with the shields in front of the
pikemen because archers are
really good effective against them
now what's going on
they're sending like little Scout
parties after it's just not working out
well for them no we don't have to chase
them
nerds I hear you PS5 blows
I'm definitely a nerd there's no denying
that
all right let's get this over here
all right so
I'm pretty confident with this
all right so they just like regular
you know
as always do this
let's do this format
and let's go straight for the City Gate
first question
come on all right let's do this
all right get those archers
Cavalry we don't want them messing up
the Pikeman too much
it's fun man I really enjoy it
we gotta take out this
The Archers and the fire will do it
pretty fast
let's push straight down let's not even
right there there's the piping let's get
them
let's get the front gate
oh man there's a lot in there we ain't
got that front gate fast
all right front Gate's done we gotta go
for those archers
the town as they board down on the key
all right now go back for the Pikeman
we want those archers to focus on the
pikemen and we want the man of arms to
go after the archers
uh there's not many archers left
foreign
the Pikeman just destroyed those archers
uh we want to push them
we want to do an up
get through this one
there's the York keep we should we might
be able to get in there hold up
let's get these people in there
come on
go go go go
you go for them
oh The Archers are just tearing me up
get the archers
oh my God yeah let's let's pull back
pull back pull back everyone pull back
pull back everyone pull back
man
yeah you need to pull back too
it'll take them a little bit to rebuild
come on demands
oh
man they
they really pushed me
there's a lot there
you got some Pike man some Cavalry so we
need some piping for that we need a lot
of archers like a lot of archers if
we're gonna win this
man we had a lot of people we don't
really have too many people anymore
um
no we don't need a farm
we don't eat that either we need a
another one of these
no we're done mining gold we don't need
no more gold
let's split the the team up
because we're gonna need more of these
all right
One's Gonna be making that one's gonna
be making that
and then we're gonna have one making
horses
we got to get more food
we have
then make five each
oh God man
this Gold's almost gone 800.
I wonder where I can find more gold at
if I need it
I wonder where they're getting their
gold at
I don't know
I don't know if I'll absolutely need it
oh we got Calvary
Calvary Pikeman
I should be able to handle them with
this
but just in safe side
I need more farming going on here
all right everyone
we need these
we also
need these there
oh we got a little bit archers back
all right
we got a little bit of capital we need a
lot of archers though
like they're really taking us out with
those archers
um
we don't have a lot of wood anymore
that's 11.
I need you
over here
oh my God man
[Music]
I'm tired of telling these people what
to do
I mean you don't have a lot of gold what
are you doing
well I guess it's because I was
technically telling them to deposit the
goal because they already have the gold
so I should have hit the gold so they
would just proactively deposit to go
that's what was going on
is is looking spooky guys it's looking
spooky chat
that's not a lot of gold left
a little bit under a thousand
and they're not really hitting me if
anything strong
but it's concerning
um
so I can sell Stone
for that
all right
we're gonna go after them again chat
we're gonna go after the game what we're
gonna do
is we're gonna hit them hard now they
had a lot for those of you that was here
when we hit that base they flushed this
straight back they pushed us straight
back
but I got a plan
and we're gonna do it probably not I'm
probably gonna lose
especially when this Gold's gone it's
about to be gone now
20. 10.
over
so there's all the gold
but the good thing is I can take the
rest of this Cobblestone which is like
350. it's not a lot but it will let me
be able to
for the most part
sell it a little bit if I have to
all right so
get the soldiers the Pikeman I don't
have a lot of Pikeman should have
probably got more Pike but I didn't see
a lot of Cavalry though
maybe it's not as necessary that
everyone else I don't know
I could probably use some trees I gotta
spend some of the resource I have
when this is over I'll probably have
some new trees I don't know if there's a
if there's a wood place around me but
I'm gonna try
all right so let's let's have them cut
trees down
worst case scenario they gotta go all
the way to you know the um here
oh there
yeah I could use these soldiers
all right let's make probably
let's make a couple more of these and
then we'll we'll hit them
I don't know how successful we're gonna
be it's gonna be a very strong fight
because like what I'm worried about is
them flanking me with the with those
archers and those Pikmin they had a lot
of them I'm worried about that but I
think if we go in there with the Cavalry
and we hit them hard enough we might be
fine
guys ready for this man this is gonna be
crazy it's gonna be crazy
yeah see they had to go back to the uh
City Hall to deliver the wood that's
fine
you know it could be more efficient I
could probably build a
something for it like you know lumber
yard or something I probably should be
honest with you to make that quicker
let's just take a couple of them and
make one
let's put it right here
and then let's have another one built
it'd just be quicker see what the the
point of this is we want it to be as
efficient as possible they have to go
all the way to City Hall it takes them
longer to do it but if they have a
lumber yard near them they go straight
to the lumber yard I shouldn't need to
really check too much I don't think
they're going to send anything worthy of
anything yeah for the most part they're
going to run from anything I sent out
them
and that's fine I don't really see them
putting too much of a fight
all right let's try this
all right so let's see what we got here
let's get everyone here
we got 19 archers and 13 Pikeman I think
we can do this chat I think we can do
this I think we got this I think we got
this
man my neck is stiff
all right
oh my God
what's up
90.
or eel
e i Eli or how you want me to pronounce
your name fan
all right here we go here we go
here we go
I wish I could zoom back a little bit
more
it should give you the option to zoom
back a little bit more
all right so we got some Pikeman
it's not too much but we got archers for
the pikemen and Calvary for uh The
Archers
and we got uh the the worst thing is
they're slow movement so we're gonna
have to rely on the Cavalry but they got
them pikemen in front of them
man look at this
all right all right so what we're gonna
do
I think they built some structures over
there
let's burn these down
I don't know if it's gonna do anything
but
it'll help us
make me feel better for the people I'm
about to lose
all right so
let's send the cavalry
listen to archers
let's send this person
all right so we got that going out now
let's send these after the archers
send them after the pikemen
man we really need these
we need these archers dealt with
hey
all right it's time to back out back out
all of you back out
back no back get them
we got a couple Pikeman we can do a
little bit of damage
all right let's
move up a little bit
when I'm worried
is those archers
all right so we have let's have 10 of
those being made
let's have a bunch of Pikeman no
actually no Pikeman
I don't think pikeman's gonna help us in
this scenario
um
yeah let's do this blacksmith
all right
let's try to find some of these units
that they're building because obviously
in any of these RTS there's building
units to build these things and maybe if
we can find them we could stop them from
building some of these
[Music]
it's taking a little bit too long to do
that I'm gonna be real with you
I need this food being made
food make it
okay did we build the blacksmith yes
weapon damage 103
Siege
we're building all that
okay I I especially the siege because we
can use that to get them before they
even do anything nah come on let's do
this
yes it's on PC game pass
what is this
it's their blacksmith
oh what are we under attack with
oh God go go over there
I already had a market I don't even know
why I spent that
all right let's keep them there
all right move on
all right so the siege thing's done
I can't remember where they said I can
build it though
is it a long range
no it's not
barracks
where can I build that
fittedly or
foreign
it's not worth it
losing this little bit of people have
there
oh my God where is
where did they say I can build that at
because it would be so much helpful if I
had something like that
um Barracks Outpost
archery Stable Market blacksmith
the Staples right here
they got a lot of archers
[Music]
are you gonna throw the fire or what man
ever played battle rounds
um is that one with the magic that you
turn into a chicken when uh you get
defeated
is that the one we're referring to here
I gotta just clarify that's what you
mean
thank you
man these
oh God
oh God
I do have some Cavalry but I don't know
if that's gonna mean anything
I need them back
I need Pikeman too
an Archer
I know I don't think I've played that
game
there we go
I have not played that game Eli
I need a scout
they've been making food for a while but
I feel like they take them forever to
make food
oh my God man
it's not looking good for us man I've
ran out of money cobblestone
you know I think maybe
I can sit in a scout out and look for
more resources
it's like my only real option right now
I mean there's lots of trees I won't run
out of trees
quit me
all right the food's just not helping
Archer is just
I got a lot of wood which I could sell
the wood
Sellwood for some gold
I can sell quite a bit of it too
huh
military 29
I need that Scout
and have the Scout look around there
[Music]
I'll have to try it man
uh unique to Norman's
can I level this up again
all right house
Outpost
wall
hmm
I'm getting a lot of wood
all right
I got enough
to stop myself from getting killed
I feel like I can make a base here
go across
thank you
I need something else
I don't even feel like this is the end
of the mission to kill this thing
because there's like still a big portion
of the map we haven't seen so I felt
like you're going to see that once you
take this keep
oh my God
all right so there's a bridge there of
some sort
so let's go across the bridge
maybe I can flank him
it looks like this is where they've been
getting wood from
us is the other
okay
this is another whole base
we don't really need that
all right what's going on here
I'm just gonna go in there with a bunch
of our of these people
these people on Pikeman
and some archers obviously
man the food is just killing me
the only thing that I'm able to stay
afraid a little bit is I can sell the
wood that I'm making
him on this but I can't do that forever
I was just gonna go for us chat
sagittarina
all right we got a lot of archers
I hit him
got some Calvary
you don't necessarily need that Scout
right now
we don't got a lot of stuff left at all
got enough wood though to feed an army
foreign
I still feel like we don't have enough
we have more of these people but we need
way more
and I'm starting to run out of resources
in general
so enough of these
I got wood coming to me from a couple
different sources so it's helping out a
little bit but it's still not enough
why can't I build more of these not
enough resources you need gold
oh I need gold to build those
let's sell some of this
now let's build some of those
are the last push man
win or lose I'm in the Stream
but we gonna win
because I'm gonna hit it from that Left
Flank I don't think they're gonna see
that coming
[Music]
so we have 17 of these so far and we're
building more
this is where I want to go I want to
attack this side
they just got a lot of archers
some pikemen I feel like right now like
Cavalry is just not the answer
but I got a little bit in my Army just
to be on the safe side
right now I have
10 Horsemen that we can rely on
all right
let's do this
all right let's go oh there's gold over
there
but she's probably gone
man
I've chopped all the wood
got just about everything guys
we're gonna go ahead and start attacking
this
attacking the uh
the gate we want that gate open
because in our army when it gets there
it will attack uh for the most part
everything we need
I'm curious that they're gonna like
respond with that army
I don't got nothing
all right
we're going in
all right we're going
we in there folks
we're going straight for the fort
foreign
[Applause]
oh my God just go where you're supposed
to
uh
that's fine that's fine focus on my
leader
foreign
this place down
burn it
come on go around
burn it
burn it
yeah that's a wrap guys
I'm gonna call it a stream here I got
some stuff I gotta do I gotta eat some
food call the girlfriend see how she's
doing uh clearly I suck at these games
I don't think necessarily think it's
because I suck at them I just gotta get
a little more
experience playing this particular game
but I appreciate everyone coming by man
until next time this is